today I'm going to be talking about some
interesting projects that were from
technical services team has done of
course you would notice that we're
calling it were from global technical
services and the reason behind that is
initially when technical services team
came into being there was just one team
and we actually grew very rapidly we saw
a lot of success and not just success in
terms of numbers but also in terms of
the results that we could actually get
to and the customer satisfaction number
of people who became interested with the
newer kinds of things that the great
things that can't that they could do
with Wolfram technologies we became like
partners and what that led to is
starting an entire new group in Europe
so they are called Wolfram rel technical
services we're the global team so we
cover north america south america and
asia and pacific and not so except
everything except for europe and that's
why you see that global there of course
what the projects that i will be
presenting today they're all done by the
global technical services team well has
done their own projects they are not
included here at such and let me tell
you a priority that the the idea behind
this presentation is to basically paint
the picture of what kinds of things can
be done using were from technologies I
may not go so much into the details of
exactly how we did that of course if you
would be interested in that then feel
free to feel free to catch me after the
talk we also have technical services
booth in the basement we are available
there for any discussion that you may
have it could be you know to know more
about these projects or it could be
about discussing your own project ideas
or challenges you welcome so starting
how many of you already
no about the technical services group in
the offerings that we have so majority
doesn't so I'll go through their first
three slides very very quickly we have
three major offerings through the
technical services team first we call as
project support which is like you know
standard consultancy kind of work where
customer provides us with specifications
and data we you know we come up with a
cost estimate for that and if that fits
customers plans we determine the
deliverables we do entire design
implementation deployment we can also do
support and of course what I'm also
mentioning here is that we have tried to
keep it very flexible so even if a cost
estimate is given but we end up doing it
you know in small amount of time than
the estimate then you know you get
automatic reference so that's very
useful but the last point I would like
to emphasize on that one can sign up for
you know in multiples of one hour which
is that it's a very very small amount of
money that's involved but the idea is
that one should not feel hesitant
approaching us it could be like one hour
of brainstorming with us just one hour
of discussion or Roman are of technical
you know help that we can provide the
second offer which is somewhat
contrasting from the first one is that
in this case we do not ask for
specifications a priori because I
personally came across several customers
where they themselves were sort of
evolving in the process of identifying
what they would like to have they know
that there are there are you know
certain problems so there are certain
gaps in the workflow or you know
whatever work that they are doing so we
work with the customer as the process
actually evolved so that has become
extremely popular now because you know
we work as an extension of their team in
a collaborative fashion so in one sense
if you're using wolfram technologies
then you always
have a team ready to help you with that
so that's what actually differentiates
this from project support of course we
also do advanced training so if you want
to learn how to do your projects all by
yourself then we will provide that
training that could be related to
specific domains of knowledge of course
you know we don't just tell you exactly
how each of the function in inversion
language works also the according domain
knowledge that is required to use those
functions in most effective ways and I
am putting this up here for a reason so
this refers to you know the revenue that
we have sort of the breakup of the
revenue we had in 2015 you can see that
project support had the largest chunk
because that's more traditional model
but what as I said I have been
recognizing more that customers are
looking for partners you know with who
we can actually they can come up with
ideas and and try things out and
implement so if you notice the
propulsion or development support which
is that kind of work this is actually
growing I'll not be surprised at all if
actually this becomes more than fifty
percent of our revenue all together
again the idea is that you always have a
partner to work with you so let me get
started with some of the examples now
one thing I should mention here is that
whatever concept that I'm going to be
talking about they are inspired by the
problems that customers have faced and
the projects that we have work done but
then they are not like one-on-one match
and the reason behind that obviously our
customers have NDA with us and they
would like to keep that niche with
themselves you know the business
advantage that generally comes with the
ideas that they carry so I'm going to be
presenting more in terms of concepts but
these concepts are not at all
theoretical and
on the other side these are all that
have been implemented using virtual
technologies and have be done actually
quite effectively so in this particular
case this is like a performance analyzer
platform we found that lots and lots of
companies are actually collecting lots
and lots of data but amazingly majority
of the companies are not able to use
that data effectively at all not just
effectively effectively at all and the
reason behind that is that you know data
is in desperate repositories and in you
know very different types of formats and
managed by different entities in fact
just day for yesterday we had three hour
long meeting with one of the largest
companies you know in the world pretty
much in terms of their revenue I can't
name them here but they work with
probably hundred different consultants
and consonants are actually managing
their data and to get one view of that
data maybe one month of work for that
why because they have to go to the
consultant conveyed to them you know
what's required and then the consultant
starts putting the data together and all
kinds of situation that's why they have
come to us and we are in talk to develop
a integrated platform for them so here
as you can notice this is giving a view
into a data set where different you know
it involves different buildings in this
concept it could be any entity it could
be any property as you can see here and
there maybe you know hit our keys of
entities you know like regions and then
sub regions and then customers and then
employees and whatnot of course you know
you're familiar with the more
interactive kinds of features that
manipulate comes with and such so you
know those features are available here
but what makes it more interesting is
that the amount of data that we are
talking about here is extremely large
it's not in you know integrate in it was
not in an integrated platform at
so what we did is we basically developed
a data architecture for this company and
so the way it works now is that data is
getting fed in on a daily basis and
every night the back end of this system
actually crunches that data aggregates
it stores it in a particular format but
in addition to that also develops models
and then stores those models so when the
end user comes in which may be in
officials from this company they can get
this snapshot very very quickly and
easily and and remember that this is
actually connecting to data source this
is of course just a conceptual
presentation by the actual system it's
connecting to a data system or data
repository which represent the entire
country an entire big country but then
getting the snapshot is actually as fast
as this and of course you know we
provided for different controls over
that what they specifically asked for us
from us was be able to get to any view
of this using those controls be able to
get the data I would get the plots out
get their stats out so that they can
then use it for you know business
intelligence kind of situations so
reporting and such of course you know
comparing different properties
associated with those entities that's
extremely interesting to them so in this
case as you can see you know you're
choosing certain specific entities and
then certain properties two of them and
then comparing that with of course you
know similar options related to
exporting the data and such times versus
flow this was of direct importance to
them because again they wanted to see
how the correlations actually work in
terms of these two parameters so again
this is feeding into the large data set
this is this a very interesting view
they call it differentials what
basically it's doing is that it's taking
data from a certain period
and comparing that to another period and
this is where the model comes into
picture because any real-world data and
you know that they're not going to come
at the same frequency the quality is
going to be different and such but when
you want to do differentials then you
need the two data sets to be uniform so
those models come in handy here to be
able to do these differentials now what
we are looking at looks random and
that's the good news for you know for
this entity they want to see that the
differentials actually should be random
because if there is a certain trend then
they need to take an action it could be
a positive thing but still they need to
know what actually they're talking about
now you can see this is a very
interesting view this shows the original
data set and these are the differential
so although there was a clear you know
jump in in the magnitude here where the
differentials actually still remain
largely random of course we can apply
statistical tests to these four tests of
randomness to make sure that we are not
missing something just because you're
looking at visually as such that was not
done in this project but totally doable
so that is one idea again the what is
terrific about this system is the way
that we architected the entire data
structure and the speed with which we
are able to make these queries so I'll
move on to another example this is a
startup company called bio in gender
comm we took permissions from them to
share their name of course they were
happy to be mentioned here you can go to
buy engine com if you would like they
have come out with a very very
innovative idea in fact it was way back
in 1940's that Paul Dirac came with the
idea of bra kept notation some of you
who were from physics background or
quantum mechanics background you will be
familiar with that but they are up
buying that to health data to health
industry data and of course it can be
applied to other domains as well the
idea behind this whole you know direct
network at the as they call it is that
if if you can represent you know vast
amounts of data which may be quite
unstructured in the form of these
bracket notations and then build what is
called as hdn hyperbolic hyperbolic
direct network then there is lot of
information that can be derived from
that network that information gives you
probabilities of different scenarios or
different properties and that then can
be used for diagnostic purposes so in
this case again this is dealing with
large amounts of data coming from you
know different health providers and such
so what we are showing you here is
actually a prototype we are in phase 2
of this prototype they first wanted to
check you know just the core of the
technology how well that can be
implemented in Wolfram language and now
what they're going to do is we're in the
process of deploying it in the cloud and
with another three to four weeks in fact
they'll be opening it up to public for
you know so that public can play with it
in fact what's going to be very very
amazing is that public will be able to
upload their own data set which doesn't
know anything about bracket notations or
anything like that but the system will
process that and of course we are
providing some extra controls for that
reason because you're talking about
large amounts of data you know how much
of data you want to process from your
data file certain you know limitations
or that you may want to put just to save
on time and such how many variables you
want to be working with and just to give
you a sense of things here you're saying
you know max number of columns being 46
but generally the datasets may have as
many as 150 to
different columns different parameters
that they have to work with and in
different scenarios they may like to
actually select or deselect different
properties given you know what kind of
inferences that they want to do so as
you can see they're here what happens is
that from the first screen we selected a
certain sets of columns that need to be
processed then the system actually goes
back and processes those columns and
creates what is called as a tag pool and
it's like a gigantic pool we are talking
about gigabytes and gigabytes and
gigabytes of tag pool that is created
now this is what actually made this
application very challenging from
implementation point of view because
imagine you know the number of variables
you may be working with is 150 or 200
and then you know I mean that's the
original data set and you may be pulling
out let's say 90 of those variables that
you want to deal with it and then you
may want you know six five or six
different parameters that you need to
operate on and such and this works with
you know combinations of the of the
properties yeah now these these tags
actually correspond directly to the
properties that you're working with so
these are not the standard tax that
you're talking about and they call it
tag because that's how the probabilities
get calculated so it's like any piece of
historical health data that you have
that has a certain information content
to it that tag represents so one piece
of data let's say one row may have five
different tags or twenty different tags
associated with it what it means is
whenever there has to be an inference in
for you know any set of properties these
are the pieces of data which are going
to be contributing to that inference so
that's the idea of the tag that anyway
so what it does is creates that tag
in this case as you can see 1.7 million
texts were created and this was just a
test data said that we were working with
so we could be working with you know
like hundreds of millions of those of
course you know there's a prototype we
wanted to show what are the variables
that you're working with at this time I
think they should add up to 46 that we
showed in the previous screen and then
what's interesting now this looks a
little bit geeky here but this is the
kind of query that can be passed on this
is a very very simple query it can be
much more complex and if you notice that
we have provided this much of space
because the query may run this long so
the idea here is you know person with
age 30 male glucose level of 80 smoking
given that he does smoke and his
systolic is around 120 of course when
there is a continuous variable the
system is intelligent enough to break
that into bins and then work with those
bins so queries like this can be made
and that the system is going to return
what we call as Zeta probabilities
associated with that hyperbolic direct
network so these are the Zeta
probabilities of course this is forward
and this is backward backward
probability what that means is a given B
is forward and be given a this backward
and this does not use the classical
probability system it uses Clifford
probability and Clifford probability
your probabilities can go beyond hundred
percent but that's how that works now
one may say well this does not seem very
interesting from you know users point of
view this is actually a very very
important milestone because beyond this
what we are going to do that's like
phase three is that there will be
another layer added to the system where
the end user will be able to ask
questions in plain English then the
system is going to convert that into
query in the form of bracket notations
and
it's going to then work on the that the
tag pool and develop and come up with
those probabilities so eventually now
you can see a direct correlation with
the the kinds of Diagnostics that can be
done of course along with that you may
like to understand what the data looks
like what are the properties associated
with it so as you can see you know these
are different fields you are looking at
counts and you know descriptive
statistics in addition to that we
provided for being able to look at
specific demographics on the first
screen you could choose which variables
you want to use for demographics and
then select and get you know views out
of the data that's for better
understanding that's for diagnosis and
so on of course getting you know some
visualizations out of that and so on
this gives the probabilities associated
with the data set so this can be a
diagnosis on the data set itself if
let's say it is between male and female
and you see like in this case here so we
see that there are actually issues
associated with the data set and it is
intelligent enough to recognize that
there are unknown values and how that
needs to be handled and such again this
is interesting this automatically
generates this correlation network of
different variables and the density of
these edges in representation that
represents the strength of the
correlation one can go back and click on
one of them any of these and get the
according correlation out so this is
correlation between systolic BP and
Vassar comes waist circumference so all
people like me they're here that's very
good news because future looks bright
there's another company very very
interesting company called healthcare
TTU what they have done is in the health
industry there is again Lord of data
being you know collected however when it
comes to the claims that are made like
you know you go see a provider and then
the day sender claimed to your insurance
company then there is a repayment
sometimes it's not done because you know
your insurance company does not cover it
or let's say insurance is not there in
place at all so all the expenses that
you know public incur from these health
providers there is a there's a lot of
uncertainty associated with repayment of
that so claims are certain but payments
are not and you cannot do business if
you know you do not know whether you're
going to get the your money back or not
or you do not know how much money is
going to come back and even if you do
not know when that money is going to
come back and the situation is and I was
a little bit surprised that that's how
it is as of now even today but it's a
fact that it's a mess what it basically
leads to is that the help providers are
dealing with very very difficult
scenario in terms of what they can
expect in terms of their revenue flow
and the banks are very hesitant touching
on that because they don't know how much
risk is involved so what this company
has done is that they have come up with
a very very innovative idea to fill that
gap and basically what it does is again
there are historical claims data which
includes claims and repayments in
instances where repayments have been
there they basically collect that data
create a very large pool and then they
model that data appropriately and I'm
not free to tell you exactly how that
modeling is done because that's what
this company is going to learn from
there already and they convert that pool
of claims which are still unpaid into an
asset that asset comes with a known
probability of repayment and I will talk
a little bit more about it once that's
quantified then banks can deal with it
they know how much of risk is they
err what kind of a revenue flow they can
expect and then if banks are then on
board the hospitals are going to get
their money they can continue operating
the fact is that many of the hospitals
are shutting down their emergency care
rooms because they have not been able to
deal with this and what we have done is
we worked with the CTO of this company
who is basically the brain behind it and
implement the entire model this is just
a snapshot that he gave me to share with
you that basically tells us that time
frame this is timeline at which you can
expect that much of free payment so this
is like 30 days 60 days 90 days and the
second thing that I talked about is
what's the risk associated with that
particular asset so bank can use this
directly so I'm going to just give you
another one minute overview of the last
example this is conceptual although
again we have done something very
similar you know all the companies you
know they have different teams different
workflows then either we you know we go
pick an off-the-shelf product and work
with it or just you know keep it manual
so what this company did is let us not
do that can they came to us and asked
can you create a custom product for us
which takes into account of workflows
our needs and then automates it as much
as possible again here what we are
showing you is you know this is for
example dealing with clients some
mundane things like scheduling meetings
of course you have different tools to do
that but what about an integrated system
and here is why this blank thing can be
all the products or offerings services
offerings that you have and what this
system basically does is that it allows
you to go through you know to to provide
all those data and information just for
an example when what comes to you mostly
it's in the form of emails and then you
go back create your to-do list imagine
team which is working with this kind of
system and something's already doing it
by the way that gets automatically
triage by the system when you approach a
when you reach your office next day
morning it has a ready-made to-do list
for you based on all the requests that
have been made it has the collection of
all the data and information that you
may be working with you're sitting with
your client of your customer and you
will have all the information in one
place not only that it is built in with
in this case it was built in this
specific logic that they use to offer
different products so even as you know
let's say it's a sales person it's a
manager they are talking to the client
they are getting automatic
recommendations of the products and
services that they can offer so it's
amazing because as he's busy talking the
system is helping him with all the
resources and decision making so anyway
that was the last example think we have
an all-new sort of time